Дані про втрати своєї армії міноборони Росії не оновлювало з 25 березня.
Тоді було заявлено, що загинула 1351-на особа.
Україна власні бойові втрати також не оприлюднює, але майже щодня публікує
свіжу інформацію про російські.
Київ станом на кінець травня оцінює безповоротні втрати Росії у так званій "спецоперації",
як це називає Кремль, приблизно в 30 тисяч.
1351 чи 30 тисяч загиблих? Різниця в 20 разів.
Усі підрахунки є приблизними. Але таких малих цифр бути не може.
Є достатньо фотографій, які підтверджують знищення бойових машин. І у всіх були екіпажі.
Якщо танк вибухне за секунду, ніхто з екіпажу не врятується - усі загинуть.
І тому можна сказати, що російські цифри вже в березні були невірними
та, безумовно, занижувалися. Якщо взяти дві третини від того, що, за словами українців,
вони знищили, це і будуть приблизні цифри.
Оцінка груба, але ми отримаємо близько 20 тисяч убитих і, ймовірно,
ще близько 40 тисяч важкопоранених, які не зможуть повернутися в стрій.
Деякі експерти вважають, що річ ще й у методиці Росії підрахунку своїх втрат.
Як приклад, історія з екіпажем затонулого крейсера "Москва".
Всі, хто не був врятований або чиє тіло не було знайдено, оголошені Росією зниклими безвісти.
Так було і з матросом Єгором Шкребцем. Його батькові в офіційній відповіді
військової прокуратури було сказано, що Єгора оголошено безвісно відсутнім у військовій частині.
Крім того, міноборони РФ, за словами експертів, наводить завідомо неповні дані.
Російське міноборони рахує тільки своїх. Воно не рахує луганських міліціонерів
чи донецьких ополченців, найманців, Росгвардію, кадировців.
Українці бачать ворога, яка їм різниця, хто це. При тому що українці самі не всіх можуть порахувати.
Це поки що складно.
9 травня Путін, хоч і завуальовано, визнав наявність втрат у принципі.
Виступаючи з промовою на параді перемоги, він сказав про допомогу дітям загиблих.
Загибель кожного нашого солдата та офіцера - це горе для всіх нас.
Особливу підтримку надамо дітям загиблих та поранених товаришів.
Указ про це сьогодні підписано.
В указі, оприлюдненому на сайті Кремля, йдеться про те, що 10 відсотків бюджетних місць
у російських вишах буде зарезервовано для дітей військовослужбовців,
які загинули під час так званої "спецоперації".
Можливо, це непряме підтвердження того, що втрати дуже великі,
й без адресної допомоги конкретним сім'ям не обійтися.
Це теж свідчить про те, що втрати катастрофічні. Тому що, якби йшлося про 1300 загиблих
та кілька тисяч поранених, не було б цієї проблеми.
Досить було б сказати - хлопці, от грант вам іменний на навчання.
Ще однією ознакою військових втрат є смертність молодих чоловіків у регіонах.
З 24 лютого в середньому по Росії вона виросла на більш ніж 18 відсотків.
Британська розвідка порівнює російські втрати в Україні за три місяці з тими,
що зазнав СРСР за 9 років війни в Афганістані.
Ціна, яку платять росіяни за своє незаконне вторгнення - це ціна,
яку має визнати російське керівництво.
Варто зазначити, що в оцінках російських втрат британці є досить обережними.
Вони називають цифри вдвічі нижчими, ніж українська сторона - близько 15 тисяч.
Саме стільки загиблих радянських військових було в афганській війні.
В Афганістані основні бої - контрпартизанські: міни, фугаси, обстріли.
Так і накопичуюються ці 15 тисяч, частина яких це поранені, які померли від поранень.
Тут все-таки війна з регулярною армією.
Її вогнева міць набагато вища, ніж у моджахедів.
Незалежні журналісти-розслідувачі змогли поіменно ідентифікувати
понад дві з половиною тисячі загиблих російських військових.
Кожен п'ятий із них - офіцер, а кожен двадцятий - старший офіцер.
Також незалежні розслідування підтвердили загибель щонайменше трьох російських генералів.
Це доволі незвично - особливо якщо врахувати, що українці не мають переваг у повітрі.
Тому що старші офіцери повинні керувати військами з командного центру в тилу
- за картами та комп'ютерами.
Вони вирушають на передову лише в тому випадку, якщо, по-перше,
щось іде настільки жахливим чином, що доводиться розбиратися особисто,
оскільки молодші командири не здатні впоратися з ситуацією.
І, по-друге, через слабкі засоби зв'язку - якщо у них немає розуміння
реальної ситуації на фронті, щоб ухвалити правильне рішення.
І їм доводиться опинятися на передовій, щоб там говорити з командирами,
отримувати правильне уявлення про те, що відбувається. І їх там вбивають.
Саме таке пояснення загибелі на передовій старших офіцерів російської армії
вважають найбільш реалістичним і більшість незалежних розслідувачів.
Тим часом, за даними британської розвідки, Росія вже втратила в Україні
близько третини своїх сухопутних бойових сил, стягнутих до кордонів України.